May 2008 Cod Massachusetts and it was
hot and humid and damp and sticky and it
was prediction of lightning thunder
a warning siren means lightning is close
get off the course I just said to the
other guys somebody make this putt and
we'll get right out of here
most of us were leaving the green except
for Mike I had the pain in my hand
everybody turned walk away I put the pin
in the hole turn the walk leaving the
green about 10 15 feet behind the guys
and then the loudest bang that I ever
heard in my life happened behind me it's
like a searing but very very loud noise
something bad had happened
michael--ah suffered a direct hit 30% of
his body is burned his legs were
scorched his face looked normal
his arms were a little scorched and he
was smoking literally the strike is not
fatal thanks to three strokes of luck
part of the current travels from his
head and shoulders down his right arm
and through the putter to the ground by
acting as a conductor the metal putter
reflects some of the electricity away
from Michaels body into the green
[Music]
without the putter he might be dead the
second stroke of luck warm weather
Michael is sweating sweat is salty water
full of charged particles that conduct
electricity
some of the current is diverted around
Michael not through him yet some enters
his body
current seeks the path of least
resistance the more water the better one
of the body's least resistant organ
systems is also one of the most
vulnerable the current shoots down the
spinal cord and shorts out Michaels
autonomic nervous system his lungs shut
down his heart stops four minutes
without oxygen and he'll have permanent
brain damage
immediately dick Gill and Bill Todd
start CPR it's the key to Michael
survival and the third stroke of luck
he got better slowly
why don't we construct shoulders so he
could move these two fingers and so he
progressively went right down his spinal
cord as if the motor neurons that were
knocked out came alive and they just
marked up itself down the spinal cord so
the last thing that really kicked in was
his legs that was like a five-month
process in total Michael has almost a
year of intensive rehabilitation a life
seldom changes so much in just a flash
oh I was a type-a I was a stockbroker I
jumped off a cliff since we tree skied
and scuba dive I didn't sit and watch I
was 48 and I went from 48 to 72 that so
instant age